>> I THINK IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT RECESSION NERVOUSNESS, YOU
SHOULD LOOK AT AT THE JOBS
REPORT.
NUMBERS LIKE THIS ARE JUST VERY
MUCH INCONSISTENT WITH ANY KIND
OF A RECESSION CALL.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE --
WE'RE NOT DENYING THAT WE HAVE
WORK TO DO ON INFLATION.
>> I KNOW TIMES ARE TOUGH,
PRICES ARE TOO HIGH, FAMILIES
ARE FACING THE COST OF LIVING
CRUNCH, BUT TODAY'S ECONOMIC
NEWS CONFIRMS THE FACT THAT MY
ECONOMIC PLAN IS MOVING IN
COUNTRY IN A BETTER DIRECTION.
>> LET'S LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
THE JUNE JOBS REPORT 372,000
JOBS ADDED.
UNEMPLOYMENT STAYING STEADY AT
3.6%.
WAGES ARE UP 45.1% BUT NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO KEEPING UP WITH
INFLATION.
WITH THAT LET'S BRING IN OUR
PANEL BEN DOMENECH EDITOR OF THE
TRANSOM.COM AND HOST OF THE BEN
DOMENECH PODCAST ON FOX NEWS
RADIO.
LESLIE MARSHALL DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST AND JEFF MASON WHITE
HOUSE CORRESPONDENT FOR REUTERS.
SINCE YOU ARE ON THE NORTH LAWN,
JEFF, LET'S START WITH YOU.
THE STATE OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY FOUR MONTHS AHEAD OF
MIDTERM ELECTION DAY?
>> WELL, MIKE, THE LABOR MARKET
IS STRONG AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT THEY EMPHASIZED
TODAY FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AND
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
BUT AS THE PRESIDENT SAID IN THE
CLIP THAT YOU PLAYED THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THEY DON'T THINK
THERE IS WORK TO DO.
AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED BEFORE,
INFLATION IS OBVIOUSLY VERY HIGH
AND AMERICANS ARE FEELING THAT.
BUT, THE ADVANTAGE, I GUESS, OF
THE LABOR MARKET BEING STRONG IF
THERE IS A RECESSION, IT COULD
MEAN THAT IT WOULD BE A MILD
ONE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT COULD
ALSO -- WILL LIKELY MEAN THAT
THE FED WILL HAVE A PRETTY HEFTY
RATE HIKE COMING UP.
SO, THERE ARE PROS AND CONS TO
THAT.
BUT AS AT LEAST THEY SEE SOME
GLIMMERS OF HOPE HERE TODAY.
>> Mike: LESLIE, YOU ARE OUTSIDE
THE BELTWAY WHAT'S THE FEELS IN
TERMS OF THE AMERICAN ECONOMY ON
THE WEST COAST?
>> WELL, NOT JUST ON THE WEST
COAST AND NOT JUST HERE ON THE
LEFT SIDE OF THINGS WITH MY
PARTY, PEOPLE LIKE SEEING GAS
PRICES COME DOWN AS THEY HAVE
BEEN FOR DAYS NOW.
PEOPLE LIKE SEEING UNEMPLOYMENT
LOW AND STAYING STEADY AND
PEOPLE LIKE SEEING JOB CREATION
AND JOBS REPORT BETTER THAN IT'S
BEEN.
I'M HOPING THAT'S GOING TO
TRANSCEND TO HIGHER APPROVAL
RATING FOR THE PRESIDENT.
ALL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE IS
DOOM AND GLOOM IN THE HEADLINES
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
WORDS INFLATION OR RECESSION
THAT STILL SCARES THEM.
WE ARE NOT OUT OF THE SCARY
WATERS YET.
THIS IS DEFINITELY GOOD NEWS.
I SAY THAT AS A PESSIMIST.
>> Mike: BEN, SOLID JOBS NUMBER
BUT INFLATION IS PRETTY BRUTAL,
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I THINK THERE IS VERY LITTLE
HOPE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
COALITION TO CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE AS PEOPLE LOOK AT THE
SITUATION AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THERE IS MUCH MORE REASON TO BE
PESSIMISTIC IN THIS MOMENT THAN
THERE IS TO BE OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
THE DIRECTION OF THE ECONOMY AND
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE ANY OF THAT CHANGE IN
TIME TO FURTHER DEMOCRATIC HOPES
IN NOVEMBER.
>> Mike: ALSO TODAY THE
PRESIDENT SIGNING AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER ON ABORTION.
HE VENTED HIS FRUSTRATION WITH
THE SUPREME COURT.
LET'S PLAY.
>> IT THE TRUTH IS TODAY'S
SUPREME COURT MAJORITY THAT IS
PLAYING FAST AND LOOSE WITH THE
FACTS.
I'M ASKING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT MUCH LIKE THEY
DID IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS ERA TO
DO SOMETHING, DO EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER TO PROTECT THESE
WOMEN SEEKING TO INVOKE THEIR
RIGHTS.
>> Mike: JEFF, IS THAT JUST
FRUSTRATION FROM THE PRESIDENT
SINCE HE REALLY DOESN'T HAVE
CONTROL OVER THE SUPREME COURT.
>> YEAH.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION THERE.
BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU JUST SAID,
MIKE, AND BECAUSE HE CAN'T
ACTUALLY DO THAT MUCH WITH
EXECUTIVE ORDERS ON THE ISSUE OF
ABORTION.
HE ISSUED THE ONE THAT YOU WERE
JUST REFERRING TO.
IT DOES A FEW THINGS.
IT SEEKS TO PROTECT ACCESS TO
ABORTION AND TO CONTRACEPTION
FOR WOMEN, BUT THE TRUTH IS I
DOESN'T HAVE THAT MUCH AUTHORITY
TO DO THAT.
THAT AUTHORITY IS NOW WITH THE
STATES.
>> Mike: LESLIE, THERE HAVE BEEN
CALLS BY THE LEFT FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO DO SOMETHING ON
ABORTION RIGHTS IS IT ENOUGH?
>> WELL, IT'S NOT ENOUGH BUT HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE POWER TO DO
ENOUGH OR TO DO MORE.
CERTAINLY, THIS IS GOING TO
APPEASE SOME, BUT IT IS NOT
ENOUGH.
IT'S VERY SCARY WHEN YOU HEARD
KEVIN McCARTHY YESTERDAY, YOU
KNOW, TOUCHING UPON A FEDERAL
BAN, WHICH WE THINK REPUBLICAN
ALSO DO IF THEY GET THE HOUSE,
THE SENATE, AND THE WHITE HOUSE
NOT IN THE MIDTERMS BUT IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION.
AND, OF COURSE, THERE IS A
CONCERN ABOUT REPUBLICANS TRYING
TO LIMIT THE ABILITY FOR WOMEN
TO TRAVEL INTERSTATE EVEN THOUGH
CURRENTLY PROTECTED THAT COULD
ALWAYS BE CHANGED.
ROE V. WADE WAS PROTECTED AND
THERE SINCE 1973.
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING THE BEST
THAT HE CAN.
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
DO IF THEY DON'T LIKE THIS
DECISION IS GET OUT AND VOTE IN
NOVEMBER AND VOTE FOR PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO PROTECT A WOMAN'S
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS.
>> Mike: BEN, WHAT ABOUT THAT?
DOES THAT ENERGIZE DEMOCRATS IN
IT NOVEMBER'S MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
>> UNFORTUNATELY VIRTUALLY
ANYBODY ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
WHO IS GOING TO BE ENERGIZED BY
THIS TYPE OF RHETORIC WAS
ALREADY GOING TO BE VOTING
ANYWAY.
THIS IS NOT A SITUATION WHERE
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE SOME KIND OF
EXPLOSIVE TURN AROUND FOR THEM.
AND A BIG PART OF THAT HAS TO DO
WITH FRANKLY EXTREME POSITION
THAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OCCUPIES ON THIS ISSUE.
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A
NINE MONTH SPREAD.
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THIS
SORT OF LEVEL OF SUPPORT FOR
ABORTION INCLUDING TAXPAYER
FUNDING, THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
JUST HAS NOT BEEN A MAJOR
POPULAR POINT FOR THEM FOR SOME
TIME NOW.
AND I THINK THAT JOE BIDEN AND
HIS PARTY ARE RUNNING RIGHT INTO
THE TEETH OF THAT BECAUSE IT
TURNS OUT THAT ROE V. WADE
DESPITE BEING FRAMED AS
SOMETHING SETTLED AND POPULAR
AND THE LIKE AND A LOT OF THE
MEDIA FRAMING AND POLLS OVER THE
YEARS HAS NOT TURNED OUT TO BE
THAT POPULAR AND WILL NOT TURN
OUT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE TO BE
SOMETHING THAT CHANGES THE
DYNAMIC HEADED INTO THE
MIDTERMS.
>> Mike: ALL RIGHT.
THERE WILL BE PLENTY MORE DEBATE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE GOING INTO THE
FALL.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR A MOMENT IN
THE SHOW OUR VIEWERS LOOK
FORWARD TO, WINNERS AND LOSERS.
JEFF, WHY DON'T YOU LEAD US OFF.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FOR WINNERS FOR THE WEEK I PICK
DON McCAIN THE LATE SENATOR
AND THE OTHER PEOPLE YESTERDAY
WHO RECEIVED THE MEDAL OF
FREEDOM FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
A VERY EMOTIONAL AND TOUCHING
CEREMONY AND FOR LOSER OF THE
WEEK ELON MUSK AND VERY POSSIBLY
THE SHAREHOLDERS OF TWITTER
AFTER HE SAID TONIGHT THAT HE
WAS PULLING OUT OF HIS DEAL TO
BUY THAT SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANY.
>> Mike: ALL RIGHT, LESLIE, YOUR
TURN.
>> I'M GOING TO GO LOSER FIRST.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE FOR ONCE
AGAIN BEING INSENSITIVE TO
VICTIMS AND VICTIMS' FAMILIES
WHEN WHEN SHE IS ALLUDING TO THE
HIGHLAND PARK SHOOTING AS BEING
A FALSE FLAG.
AND WINNERS, WELL I'M GOING TO
SAY MY STATE AND THE GOVERNOR OF
MY STATE GAVIN NEWSOM IS GOING
TO MAKE INSULIN AFFORDABLE TO
THOSE WHO NEED IT.
>> Mike: ALL RIGHT, BEN, BRING
US HOME.
>> BORIS JOHNSON IS MY LOSER FOR
THE WEEK.
REALLY A DISAPPOINTMENT IN TERMS
OF HIS TENURE AS PRIME MINISTER,
THOUGH IT IS RATHER RIDICULOUS
AS McCULLOUGH TOLD US TO SEE
THE BRITISH PEOPLE GO THROUGH A
MORALISTIC FIT NOW AND THEN.
MY WINNER FOR THE WEEK IS EXREAL
FLO RIDA AND THE FOLKS AT "FOX &
FRIENDS" THIS MORNING PUT ON AN
INCREDIBLE PERFORMANCE AND
INCLUDED IMAGE OF STEVE DOOCY
DANCING ALONG TO.
IT WAS JUST A GOOD ENJOYABLE WAY
TO END WHAT HAS BEEN